la parole est maintenant notre collègue
christiane kammermann pour le groupe est
républicain pour deux minutes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères et du développement
international monsieur le ministre
après deux millions et demi au alep deux
millions et demi d'habitants a été
coupée du monde est encerclée par les
djihadistes islamique d'esch et le faux
halal nostra qui s'entretuaient encore
voici trois à quatre semaines et sont
maintenant unis contre l'armée
officielle
la seule voie de communication d'alep
avec l'extérieur est devenu un lieu de
combat entre les forces islamistes
djihadistes et l'armée syrienne il
s'agit d'une tragédie que vivent des
millions de civils et parmi eux quelques
dizaines de français
pourquoi ne parle t'on pas de cette
tragédie dans les 1000 dans les médias
je viens d'apprendre que le blocus a été
parfaitement levée après 25 15 jours
nous devons impérativement exercer une
pression politique sur les pays qui
arment et soutiennent ces islamistes
fanatiques
après avoir été privés de nourriture de
médicaments de fioul et les sens les
habitants sont condamnés à la soif et à
l'obscurité
en effet les djihadistes islamique
contre l'eau qui arrive tous les dix
quinze jours et l'électricité qui manque
depuis des mois monsieur le ministre
nous devons absolument éviter la
tragédie humaine qui menace les millions
d'ha les pins c'est le moment pour la
france d'intervenir rapidement et
efficacement en faisant pression sur nos
alliés de l'arabie saoudite du koweït du
qatar et de la turquie
merci bon vous répondre la parole à
monsieur harlem désir secrétaire d'état
en charge des affaires européennes avait
la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice caméra nous avait évidemment
raison la situation de la ville martyre
d'alep est un sujet de préoccupation sur
lequel le ministre des affaires
étrangères alors
fabius a attiré à plusieurs reprises
l'attention de la communauté
internationale
s'agissant du blocus que vous décrivez
comme vous l'avez vous-même indiqué la
situation vient d'évoluer au cours des
dernières heures puisque les forces du
régime syrien ont repris il y à peu la
route qui avaient été perdus le mois
dernier en revanche ce qu'il faut garder
à l'esprit c'est la situation dramatique
des populations civiles c'est celle
aussi de l'opposition modérée à alep
depuis plus d'un an celle ci
l'opposition se bat courageusement
contre un doublé nuit le régime qui
poursuit ses attaques indiscriminées et
dont il faut rappeler qu'il porte la
principale responsabilité des attaques
contre les civils
comme le rappelle régulièrement les
nations unies et d'autres par dash dont
on connaît également la monstruosité et
la barbarie vis-à-vis des civils et de
tous ceux qui ne se soumettent pas à son
idéologie il n'y a donc pas de solution
uniquement militaire à la crise syrienne
et laurent fabius rappellera à samedi à
vienne nos trois priorités en
concertation avec nos panneaux
partenaires d'abord la priorité
humanitaire vous l'avez dit il faut
assurer l'accès humanitaire aux
populations la fin des bombardements
indiscriminés et il faut donc obtenir un
cessez-le-feu deuxièmement la lutte
contre le terrorisme la france pour suez
accroît ses frappes contre dash et va
déployer dans la région le porte avions
charles de gaulle
nous devons également préservé une
opposition modérée car elle est le
meilleur rempart contre les terroristes
ce n'est pas le cas du régime syrien
actuel
troisièmement la nécessité absolue je le
disais d'une solution politique globale
qui conditionne tous les progrès dans
les autres domaines les contours de
cette solution sont connus ils sont
fondés sur ce qu'on appelle le
communiqué de genève qui était issu de
discussions internationales
c'est la mise en place d'un gouvernement
de transition qui inclut à la fois des
éléments du régime au conclure de
l'opposition la préservation des
institutions de l'état syrien
mais assad devra partir parce que tant
qu'il sera là il n'y aura pas de
rassemblement du peuple syrien autour
d'une solution de paix toujours merci un
mk berman pour 12 secondes
le général de gaulle disait que cette
obligation de jouer notre rôle à nous
deux ne laissait à personne le droit
d'agir ou de parler pour nous marquent
l'esprit et la manière de notre
participation aux entreprises
internationales
on aimerait faut conclure dendre la voix
de la france plus haut et plus fort